Speaker 1: Well, yesterday was an historic
day.
There was last minute testimony scheduled
in the January six committee from a former
aide to Trump chief of staff Mark Meadows.
Her name is Cassidy Hutchinson.
This was scheduled relatively last minute.
It was expected to be explosive.
And it was in fact, it was so potentially
explosive that I even canceled yesterday's
bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: And if I cancel that, you know,
something's big is going on.
And indeed it was.
Yesterday we received testimony from Cassidy
Hutchinson, former aide to former Trump chief
of staff Mark Meadows, that Donald Trump knew
there were people at his January six rally
with guns and he wanted the metal detectors
turned off so more people could get in saying
they don't want to hurt me.
Trump was so determined to go to the Capitol
with the rioters that he allegedly assaulted
a Secret Service officer and attempted to
commandeer his vehicle.
He also threw his lunch at the wall, leaving
a ketchup stain dribbling down the walls of
the White House and so many other claims.
Let's get right into it like nothing we've
ever heard before.
Speaker 3: The impression from Mr. Meadows
that the off the record movement to the Capitol
was so possible and likely to happen that
that body had more information.
So once the president had gotten into the
vehicle with body, he thought that they were
going up to the Capitol.
And when Bobby had related to him, we're not
we don't have the assets to do it.
It's not secure.
We're going back to the West Wing.
The president had very strong, very angry
response to that.
Tony described him as being irate.
The president said something to the effect
of, I'm the acting president.
Take me up to the Capitol now.
To which Bobby responded, Sir, we have to
go back to the West Wing, sir.
The president reached out towards the front
of the vehicle to grab at the steering wheel
while.
Mr. Engels grabbed his arm, said, Sir, you
need to take your hand off the steering wheel.
We're going back to the West Wing.
We're not going to the capital.
Mr. Trump then used his free hand to lunge
towards Bobby Engle.
And when Mr. Renato had recounted the stories,
we had motioned towards his clavicles.
While.
And was Mr. Engle in the room, as Mr. Bernardo
told you this story?
He was.
Did Mr. Engle correct or disagree with any
part of this story for Mr. Tornado?
Mr. Engle did not correct or disagree with
any part of the story.
Did Mr. Engle or Mr. Varnado ever after that
tell you that what Mr. Tornado had just said
was untrue?
Neither Mr. Rinaldo nor Mr. Engle told me
ever that it was untrue.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Wow.
Assaulting.
The allegations here are assaulting a Secret
Service agent attempting to commandeer the
vehicle.
And I guess, I mean, I don't know that Donald
Trump knows how to drive.
I'm not aware of him ever driving, but I guess
attempting to redirect the vehicle towards
where he wanted to go and a determination
to go to the Capitol.
Now, this is arguably the most sort of salacious
allegation, but the undertone of all of it
is a degree of premeditation and foreknowledge
that armed, violent people would be coming
to the Capitol on January 6th and a desire
for them to be there and a desire for them
to wreak havoc and an expectation that they
would.
No one was surprised in the Trump Circle that
this is the way it went on January 6th.
Incredible allegations.
Now, there are now reports that some of the
Secret Service officers mentioned dispute
and are willing to, well, get them under oath.
Okay.
What we have right now is Cassidy Hutchinson
under oath.
And we have Trump posting untruth, social
or truth essential and claims to reporters
that Secret Service will put him under oath.
Right now, this is what we have under oath.
Okay, second series of allegations that are
absolutely outrageous, but not particularly
shocking that Trump threw a fit so large that
he launched his food at the wall.
Of course, his lunch include catch up, unclear
whether they were dinosaur shaped chicken
nuggets or what he was eating with the ketchup.
That's not a detail we have.
But Trump losing it and leaving ketchup dripping
down the wall.
Speaker 3: The physical altercation that Ms..
Hutchinson described in the presidential vehicle
was not the first time that the president
had become very.
Speaker 1: Oh, sorry.
And that's.
So first, we're looking at we're looking at
one other clip here, but we're going to get
to the catch.
Speaker 3: Up injury about issues relating
to the election on December one, 2020.
Attorney General Barr said in an interview
that the Department of Justice had not found
evidence of widespread election fraud sufficient
to change the outcome of the election.
Ms. Hutchinson, how did the President react
to hearing that news?
Around the time that I understand the AP article
went live.
I remember hearing noise coming from down
the hallway, so I poked my head out of the
office.
I saw the valet walking towards our office.
He had said, Get the chief down to the dining
room.
The president wants him to mark one down to
the dining room.
Came back to the office a few minutes later
after Mark had returned.
I left the office and went down to the dining
room and I noticed that the door is propped
open and the valet was inside the dining room,
changing the tablecloth off of the dining
room table.
He motioned for me to come in and then pointed
towards the front of the room near the fireplace
mantel and the TV, where I first noticed there
was catch up dripping down the wall and there's
a shattered porcelain plate on the floor.
The valet had articulated that the president
was extremely angry at the attorney general's
AP interview and had thrown his lunch against
the wall.
Which was causing them to have to clean up.
So I grabbed a towel and started wiping the
catch up off of the wall to help the valet
out.
And he said something to the effect of, he's
really ticked off about this.
So I would stay clear of him for right now.
He's really, really ticked off about this
right now.
Speaker 1: Wow.
Ketchup.
Ketchup down the wall.
And apparently, Trump would regularly throw
dishes.
And that was also testified to sort.
Speaker 3: Of wiping the catch up off of the
wall to help the valet out.
And he said something to the effect of, he's
really ticked off about this.
I said I would stay clear of him for right
now.
He's really, really ticked off about this
right now.
And Miss Hutchinson, was this the only instance
that you are aware of where the president
threw dishes?
It's not.
And are there other instances in the dining
room that you recall where he expressed his
anger?
There were there were several times throughout
my tenure with the chief of staff that I was
aware of either throwing dishes or flipping
the tablecloth to let all the contents of
the table go onto the floor.
Speaker 1: And there you go, just grabbing
the tablecloth and pushing it up and knocking
everything over.
This was an unhinged man.
And most importantly, all, I mean, listen,
throwing ketchup at the wall from your attendees
that your chicken tenders that you're eating,
this is not a crime.
It does go to Trump's instability on and on
and on.
But so far, there has been no dispute whatsoever
that Donald Trump knew and wanted armed people
to be let beyond the magnetometers, metal
detectors, or with their firearms.
There is no dispute from witnesses that Donald
Trump was absolutely determined to get to
the Capitol with the mob.
And there is absolutely no dispute about all
of the claims that everybody Mark Meadows,
Trump, Pat Cipollone, you know, whoever they
all knew exactly that what happened on January
six was what was expected to happen.
No dispute there.
Now, one other thing.
There are some people making Cassidy Hutchinson
out to be some kind of hero.
Cassidy Hutchinson is not a hero.
Okay.
Cassidy Hutchinson is cooperating with an
investigation.
She if she does not cooperate.
She is not like Roger Stone or whoever.
Okay.
This is a mid-level staffer.
The legal help that could be trained upon
her if she doesn't cooperate or if she lies
under oath is extraordinary.
She was part of the MAGA crowd.
She worked for Mark Meadows and Trump.
She agreed with all of it.
She at the very end, she didn't like the way
that they were trying to steal the election.
But she is not a hero.
She's acting out of self-preservation.
She was there for a year or more.
This is the testimony that we needed 12, 14,
15, 16 months ago.
Great that she's here.
To the extent that she's telling the truth,
fantastic.
But Cassidy Hutchinson is not a hero.
She is here because she's in serious legal
jeopardy if she's not here, period.
Let's now move on to the Hang Mike Pence circumstances.